it's or I'll cut your face today we're
trying weird kitchen gadgets it's the
stuff that you see in Bed Bath & Beyond
that you don't need and you're like of
course I need a melon baller
can there be a fidget spinner or
something coming out of us we're gonna
crack the egg and we're gonna get the
yolk out with this you can just do this
with an empty water bottle this is not
how you use it I can tell you right now
this is a guy who does worth it oh yeah
look at that
no cracking no sorry it does beautiful
so you just go dip it in now it's stuck
you squeeze it like full fist it and
then go in and I got a fist it yeah fist
it honestly a water bottle works better
than this so we're gonna have to use
this vagina so you hold it up like this
and then you just push you just okay
there we go oh
supposedly we're right right it's very
easy just cuz I don't think that's how
you're supposed to do it
uh-huh I feel good doing that you know
the mango honestly I could just use a
knife
so we have like a rabbit and a star car
and a bear oh my god wait this is a
hard-boiled egg we're gonna make it look
like this bunny there's a break
it becomes an egg bear and it's cute how
does this work was that supposed to be a
pun no these eggs aren't big enough
scare away it gets new both eggs
oh good what did we did this nothing
in case you don't know what thanks
that's where you went to college
Oh pizza oh wait oh I'm gonna cut again
here oh you're cutting it a very
interesting angle that you've chosen to
go in that hey go boom this is pretty
cool although fairly useless things that
only have one very particular use really
confuse me like how often are you
cutting mangos these products in theory
are a great idea and some of them are
great and then others I'm just like but
why it's the goddamn start to take to
people trying to come for our money like
I can do this on my own
[Music]